with so many contractual issues that
involve so many boldface named NFL
players going on in training camp again
earlier on in the show we had Dan Quinn
of the Atlanta Falcons Julio Jones not
holding out we also had the head of NFL
refs al River on here on the show it was
an fascinating conversation joining us
once again here on the show to talk
about these contracts that are
outstanding the former CEO of the
Cleveland Browns and senior
vice-president the Philadelphia Eagles
Joe banner right here back on the show
how you been Joe I've been doing great
good to be with you I'm keeping some
good company today thank you you know
what I'm excited it's it's that time of
year right I mean what what did training
camp mean to you in the front office Joe
you know the the hope abound you know
one of the most fun days of the whole
year was the first day of training camp
with a real quick story I shirk my son
to training camp one year the first day
he was five and he tugged on my leg
about five minutes into practice as the
debt is this what you call work even a
five-year-old got that huh picked it up
that it's the toy department of
professions so Melvin Gordon let's start
with with with him first with the Los
Angeles chargers Tom telesco doesn't
appear to be budging he said yesterday
as much as he loves Melvin Gordon he's
going to be a charger he's not playing
anywhere else Phillip Rivers on the
first day of training camp said that we
love Melvin but it's a deep position
group and no you know even he kind of
put that off to the side what do you
think he has at all that might be
leverage Joe you know he doesn't have
much is unfortunately the answer in his
particular case now we're seeing players
realized in general they have a lot more
leverage they've been using but there's
a couple of things the Chargers are one
of the strongest organizations the
league and kind of sticking to what they
believe is staying strong and not
allowing the precedent to get set that
could be used against them with other
players combine that with a position
he's at and the other players they got
in their roster you know I have a hard
time seeing him really get what he wants
now could they do a deal in the end that
maybe somewhere in between
you know hopefully a reasonable minds
prevail and that's what happens but he's
dealing with the organization it is a
very tough organization to do this kind
of thing within prevail well so what is
what what is it about the running back
position I know we talked about this
almost endlessly but here's another
instance of a young man coming out of
Wisconsin drafted very high he's put his
body on the line he has for the first
few years of his career put out when he
is healthy some serious statistics and
output why why does this seem to keep
happening in the NFL Joe so there's only
one position if you really think about
this by the discussion that running
backs not important and I was running a
team for 18 years that never paid a
running back a ton of money and I
strongly believe that most of the time
you shouldn't be paying around like a
ton of money but the reason this happens
is not because I'm aren't important it's
because it's the only position of the
entire game where the supply and demand
favors the team they're actually more
players good enough to win a
championship
position then there are teams in the
league so the running backs have a
disadvantage because the career short
and the rookie bully is what it is
and combine it with the fact you of an
abundance of talent that this position
there's no other position you can look
at even unimportant positions we would
say there are more good players at this
position I'm defining good as good
enough to win a championship with this
caliber player at this position the only
place where the supply and demand is out
of whack and favor for the team is
running back so they get stuck in this
thing with the rookie pull the shortness
of the career and a position in which
there's just more good players than the
league needs so it's a very tough place
to get the fair treatment for what
you're worth to that team at that moment
and Adam Schefter
latest report about Gordon is anywhere
between ten to eleven million dollars a
year has been offered to him by the
Chargers what do you make of those
numbers in that report
you know depending upon the detail of
the structure and the guarantees that's
about what I would have expected them to
go and I think he should take the deal I
really do I just I don't see him getting
them pushing much beyond that I don't
think they should and assuming the
guarantees are right so this is not some
you know fake looking 10 11 million
dollar average it's actually going to
collect that for a period of time I
think that's where the deal should be
and if I were him I would take it former
Eagles president senior vice president
as was his first title when he was a in
the front office there with the
Philadelphia Eagles and CEO of the
Cleveland Browns Joe Joe banner joining
me here on the Rich Eisen show last time
we chatted was after Carson Wentz got
done by the Eagles early and you said
that the Cowboys habitually do stuff
late here we are eve of training camp
first practice for the Dallas Cowboys
and everybody there in dak not signed
Joe what in the world do you think the
Joneses plan is for dak I think the jobs
wound up giving exactly a very strong
deal in the girli range and that he will
take it but just think about this if I'm
dak Prescott agent if I'm a Mary's
Cooper's agent and has everybody knows
the list is longer than that they have a
list of half a dozen players there is
good young players is there are on any
team in the league what happens when
they give in amara Koopas is not going
to leave camp but shitty sure Prescott
walk out of camp many people both in
from the team side if you're in the
front these are really really tough
decisions but people are predictable and
the history says that Jerry will stay
tough for a while and then he'll get
this deal done because they ever wrote
us with a Super Bowl this year and more
than any other player that's holding out
right now my opinion other than maybe
Michael Thomas this holdout has a chance
to affect who wins the Super Bowl you're
talking about Zeke not Jack you're
talking about Zeke Elliott right here
yes okay so you think that Jerry and
Steven Jones are gonna put on the table
something for him that's akin to the
girly contract I do I don't I'm not
saying it's gonna happen tomorrow
but it's gonna happen before the season
starts that's my prediction okay what
about Dax Prescott I think they'll get
back done I don't think they have any
choice and listen if you're if one side
is it thirty and the other side is at 32
million and you're talking about the
quarterback of the team and I'm making
up what I'm guessing is likelihood of
the gap it becomes such a small
percentage of the deal you make a deal
now if you're Michael Thomas and ones at
18 and one to 20 or 21 that's actually a
meaningful percentage of the deal at 20%
of the deal where the numbers we just
used on deck at 6% of the deal so you
find a way to get those kind of deals
done especially with its quarterback so
by the time Dallas kicks off the season
against the Giants week one do you think
all three these players are done I do
I think deck I think Zeke and I think
Amari Cooper all have deals done before
the first game of the season no kidding
well then that then obviously that would
be exactly what Cowboys fans would want
or need but I imagine it wouldn't come
without the drama of who gets done first
I think as you intimated at the top of
this conversation here
and if I was jealous I don't want to
send the message that I'm rewarding a
hold that's what I'm running over to Dex
agent or running over to Mario Cooper's
agent in the next week or so and I'm
really trying to get a deal done with
those guys and then I'm calling them
Zeke and I'm saying listen come into
camp be here for a week do what you do
we'll try to minimize the risk of injury
and then let's sit down and have a hard
conversation simple to get something
done to know the optics of worried about
the 53 other agents I have mm-hmm
there's gonna make my team in the first
game of the season and you know listen
agents hate when you say that hate when
you talk about presents they just want
to focus on their team but believe me
the smart teams worry about the
president because every agent is
watching everything thing you do and
every player is watching what every
other player gets that's why I like what
Green Bay just did to Mitch Daniels it's
people like well you know what were they
spoil no they just did something that's
going to be really hurtful because the
way he's respected as a captain of the
team sitting in the Walkman was a great
player for one to all of these messages
matter well
that's another thing I was about to
bring up with you Jill banner former
front office executive here are on the
Rich Eisen show you've been very you've
been very vocal about veterans that were
just cut on the eve of training camp
Mike Daniels you just mentioned of of
the Green Bay Packers being one what
goes into this decision do you think why
does it happen the team the benefit of
the doubt and this is hard for me to do
in the circumstance you know there's
some legitimate concern about waiving a
player early who has an injury and can
make a claim against you that said there
are ways to communicate with a player
and the agent and have a situation where
you're not cutting somebody has been
working for the team for all these years
place effectively captain of your team
the night before you were burden
reported the training camp and to
isolate that decision just in that
moment and not think about the
repercussions to the rest of the law you
lost but the feelings in the locker room
the every player on that field team
feels more vulnerable they did a week
ago there's a really good player an A+
personality captain of the team and
frankly you know real world eight
million dollars a ton of money eight
million those in the NFL today is not a
huge amount of money and you can't find
a way they've managed that situation so
it feels good for everybody
because when I was running the Eagles I
had a reputation for being tough I think
people thought tough but fair hopefully
but tough but the thought of cutting a
player on the eve of reporting to
training camp I can tell you in the 14
years Andy Reed and I were running the
Eagles that conversation never took
place
once there's no circumstance of which we
would do that you know you may keep a
player through the draft maybe he can be
traded maybe there's some other issues
like in this case he's recovering from
an injury but once you start to get
through June and July by the way I
understand they were allowed to do what
they did but there's a difference
between being allowed to do something
and it's the right thing to do so
nobody's questioning they have the right
to do what they did absolutely nothing
that woman's this but is it the right
thing to do even from a business
perspective is it the right thing to do
I mean for me that's just an unambiguous
no it's a mistake and I'm assuming Joe
banner
michael thomas gets done in New Orleans
right yeah that's that's no clear
release up right he'll get a deal and
he'll be the new highest-paid wide
receiver in the league which is what
happens when the most recent top tier
players lines and what happened and what
happens when with with wide receivers
who have contracts that are now
surpassed by Michael Thomas and then
they're guaranteed money is running out
on the contract that they currently have
well they're all frustrated is what's
leading to somebody's holdups the
players some are valid some aren't the
players have a long list of grievances
at the moment from cap money carried
over to lack of guarantees to salaries
for positions and I'm catching up with
the increases and they kept they've a
long list agreement so so you're seeing
physicians if players become more
aggressive and willing to take a stand
and frankly leverage their services I
get people all the time talking about
how well you know what leverage do they
have or what leverage does a union have
now you can create a perceived leverage
by withholding your services that's
tremendous leverage that's all the
leverage you should be I think this
really flipped with Mack last year where
everybody said whoa
not only stayed strong he planned
forward for a year he actually had to
get to a new team to get what he
deserved
and by just being you know a movable so
yeah Michael Thomas gets done and it
should be done and Julio Jones may get
done just after it just before and then
you'll have Amari Cooper snuggling right
below those guys deals and then Tyreke
he'll try to get a deal Joe Penna it's
just gonna be one big domino Joe banner
former Eagles president in front office
executive you minutes left with you sir
so looking at all 32 rosters right now
Joe okay look at just I know you don't
have them all in front of you but just
based off the top of your head which
roster to win now and for the next few
years or foreseeable future which one
would you choose I want that one
Joe banner which one is that one
I hate when I look like I'm unobjective
and my answer is going to look terribly
unobjective but my answer is clearly and
emphatically the Philadelphia Eagles why
is that well you got a strong coaching
staff you got a strong front office they
have a reasonable cap situation I think
you have the best young quarterback in
the league I understand this concerns
about Kenny stay healthy and you have
the short-term ability to dominate both
lines of scrimmage so those are all the
boxes I check as to who are the best
teams now and as I look at the age and
the contract of those players who's
likely to sustain that for the future
and I can't come up with a team that I
think is stronger on those things those
are my priorities than the Eagles well
it's funny you know I'm some of my
listeners and viewers might have thought
that you were about to choose your other
former team in the Cleveland Browns
because of how much they're high too
what do you what do you think of them
Joe so I think the Browns obviously have
much more talent they've had a very long
time and they have a challenging dynamic
I think that the defense will be a
little bit challenged to stay as good as
it was last year even with the additions
that they made and I worry a little bit
out their offensive line I'm not excited
about either tackle and they traded away
their starting guard and I'm not sure
they have a replacement so I think the
Browns are much better conversation
about that making the playoffs is
completely legitimate but I still think
they have weaknesses in a couple of
areas are important to me that doesn't
put them at the very very top group of
teams last one last one for you Joe
banner I know you're a sports fan
generally not just a former NFL
executive I wonder what you think of
what went down in the NBA over the last
few weeks where players like Paul George
Anthony Davis told their teams I want
out and and yes their general managers
and front office executives got huge
hauls in in regard to coughing them up
but general managers didn't just say no
sort of like what Tom telesco is doing
right now with Melvin Gordon I wonder
what your thoughts are as a former NFL
executive on this front Joe
well first of all fascinating to watch
five years ago if you'd asked me what
was happening over the last four years I
would have said the MBA will probably
drop in some popularity because so many
fans will be hopeless and the opposite
has happened and it's a phenomenal
example of what we're starting to see
the NFL of players realizing that the
notion that they don't have leverage but
you actually have to have leverage
versus perceived leverage and leverages
withholding your services and if you
want to see it play out in real life
you're watching it in the NBA and the
NFL I said it's less I was on your show
is going to become much more like not
gonna become like it's become more like
the NBA than what we used to say what do
you mean while the players are going to
start to use the leverage that they have
to make demand and be treated more
fairly and get what they deserve the
players you know listen if you took the
average position pay right now at the
rate that the cap is going up there are
almost no positions where the rate of
pay has gone up as fast as the little
cap increase some have actually caught
up in the last 12 months up until then I
could have made that as a blanket
statement now some are actually catching
up and they're catching up because of
the max and the Donalds and the Wilsons
and now will be the Thomases and then it
will be the Zeke Elliott's they
understand how to the power that they
have they understand when and how to try
to use it more effectively and it's
going to push up there you're gonna see
teams able to carry over less money than
they have them years for years now the
teams are carrying over massive amounts
of money I think that will get addressed
in the CBA too but why should the player
be sitting here taking a deal for let's
say 50 million dollars a year when he
thinks he's worth 18 because he hopes
the team has to spend on the rest of the
roster and what they do instead is they
carry it over the next year they're
they're really waking up to all of this
the players are talking to each other
they're more outside people talking to
the players the players are watching
what's going on the NBA they have this
long list of grievance that we talked
about briefly earlier and they're like
you know what it's it's the movie
network I'm not taking it anymore I'm
gonna stand up for myself and I'm gonna
get what I believe I deserve
some of the places like I was not a fan
of what Bell did lashes some of the
plays will overshoot in trying to stand
up for themselves and some players will
get what they deserve when they stand up
for themselves the agents are going to
play a big role in this hopefully
helping the players understand when am i
overshooting what am I getting what I
deserve
why picking a fight with the team that I
actually have a chance of winning if I
was advising Gordon I would say listen
just go can't go quietly do everything
well let me get his deal done even if
it's late in camp and then let's go back
Andrea proach them because the treasures
aren't going to cave that's just not
what they do
so I think he's putting himself in a one
down position as we would say in a
negotiation Joe banner thanks for the
time have a great rest of your summer
we'll chat we'll chat shortly thanks
again for your insight you got it Joe
banner at Joe banner thirteen great
follow on Twitter for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app